the Cleveland Browns have yet again
changed their uniforms it was just five
years ago that they unveiled the models
above with Cleveland written above the
numbers and all sorts of different color
combinations now they are back to a more
classic look they know their Cleveland
they know their the Browns and I like
the new uniforms at the bottom I like
the brown pants I love the brown on
brown that's something that they've been
wearing a lot lately the one that I
really like though Chris the one that
screams out to me football from the 70s
the second one in the brown jersey in
the way yes that's the Browns that I
remember well that's the Cleveland
Browns I remember too they got rid of
those ugly stupid orange pants thank God
that's the best thing about it and I do
like their Brown on brown as an
alternate but man just you can never go
wrong going with a classic look and they
have a classic look despite what they're
you know modern history results have
been this is still one of the greatest
organizations ever and Jim Brown more
those damn uniforms and they look good I
like the you know the old school stripe
they changed that on the jersey but I'm
with you Mike the biggest thing when I
was growing up in the 80s and Marty
Schottenheimer and Ernest Byner and
Bernie Kosar when the Browns were home
they wear white pants and a brown jersey
when they were on the road they wore
white on white and to me that's just a
classic look so I mean way to go
Cleveland I really love the unions I
really do and this is one of the rare
occasions where Nike pushes a team to
change its uniform and the change is to
adopt something old what we've seen over
the past eight years and we knew this
was coming the moment Nike got the
apparel contract because we saw what
Nike did and a bunch of colleges over
the years they're gonna push these teams
to do all sorts of funky things with the
uniforms I like the idea that what
happened here is the Browns went back to
something more classic and more
traditional and you know the point that
I'll make again and again and again the
best teams don't need to mess around
with their uniforms they don't need that
external source of intrigue and
excitement and things for people to talk
about
they win that's the thing people talk
about that's the thing they get excited
about and maybe the Browns won't have to
change these uniforms any time soon
maybe this is a sign they're laying the
foundation to give us something to get
excited about unrelated to what their
next uniforms gonna look like
well yeah I mean they should never
change they have they should have never
changed from their classic look I mean
to me that's like Yankees Red Sox
Packers Cowboys Bears you just you don't
change I'm sorry it's a classic look you
know I know that you know the Browns
haven't won a Super Bowl had never been
to one and all of that but still like I
said there's great tradition there and
you know if there is something I mean
you know that helmet when you see that
color in that helmet everybody in this
country knows who that is you know
that's unique the color seems unique I
like it and I'm glad they went back to
the old school look it's it's definitely
a better look and even within that you
know I even like that brown pants with
the white jersey look it's probably my
third favorite out of all the four
uniforms we saw but you know I'm really
a fan of all four looks but the first
two to the left like you are the real
classics to me and I want to see them in
that uniform the majority of the time I
know not every team has the same
tradition of the Browns just by way of
longevity but but I I'm a big fan of a
classic look and you stick with it
Cowboys Packers Raiders etc right and
I'm glad you finally agree with me
because you know as you're doing your
spiel for the classic looks I'm thinking
last week this guy's talking about all
the Falcons new uniforms look great
that's far from a classic look I want
okay but the Falcons have no tradition
and they don't go back to the 50s and
40s and 60s like to me there are a new
age team so they have some wiggle room
to be new a genus with their uniforms
but they have been to a Super Bowl which
the Browns haven't so they can claim
that the tradition is at least more
successful than the Brown
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports